you don't mess with the champions
surtout sur speed run heures avec à
chaque fois vous me saouler un effet non
les gens ne veulent plus là c'est fini
on s'assure d'offrir speed run heures on
va jouer sur une map qui en fait une
sorte de super smash bros melee tu
attends moi je suis une version fait
mais je te blâme 10h fait une éternité
que je peux jouer speed run est en
veille ouais moi ça va quoi et avant ça
va ça va quoi on sait de mallarmé
recyclage c'est très aimable à la portée
de la boîte avait sauvé avec tant
d'amour
vous êtes sérieux attends tu fais quoi
jackson et la 37e là aucun prof
la lâcheté
ok c'est bien les caisses maguelone l'a
fait trop de cas non pas en faire des
tonnes
le jeu de mot adéquat me casse était
temps a fait les caisses voilà et toi tu
as fait tu es jeune femme seema j'ai
gagné je fais comme l'achat délicate
j'aime beaucoup ce mois de juin était
intéressant quand tu gagnes un peu
amateur aux verrines à l'écart merci
beaucoup mais c'est très aimable et ça
c'est beaucoup moins avec quel combat le
toit on l'appelle freezer dans le milieu
hugo je mettais un gros tas dernier
moment il se passe un truc je suis un
peu deg vous à vous allez la barre toi y
en a toujours
t'étais au nord foire et éveil
attends est déjà tu te kaboul qu'est-ce
qui fait la bascule du délire oui
[Applaudissements]
monsieur pas lécher sorcières sur un
balai non je n'y arrive pas un jour là
voilà elle décède quoi on a approuvé
mardi à tétouan va là bas j'ai cassé la
boîte plusieurs mois déjà on se calme
merci ce sujet des caisses donc je fais
rien allez à dieu salue comme la péter
avec mon gars c'est glacé s'ils ne
pouvaient pas été bonne mais tu me vois
là est une bombe atomique alors je te
sors je te sens très bien
un battant et non mais bien tenté mon
grand âge bientôt c'est bien aulas c'est
pas mal ouais quand j'arrive déjà tu
étais pas invités à la fête en dessous
des 4 pas sommeil de boules au comptant
jeudi à l'ats bientôt gaza fait cet acte
horrible
oui d'icônes avoir tous les deux et la
grèce la bombe le bâtard rabat annonce
ah non mais là juste devant votre cas
mais vous allez dès que j'ai à faire
j'ai une annonce à faire de la plus
haute importance celui qui gagne cette
partie palm la première manche mais donc
que trois manches gagnantes ou non mais
si moi j'ai gagné est tu descends bâton
à paris chez le maître paru gêné par la
droite et gauche à droite à gauche à
droite à gauche ça va les gars not ok
mais hugo
j'ai bien cru qu'il allait mourir mais
qui a contribué à 38 mika compte sur moi
je te dis ça la bombe elle passe à
travers les murs je sais pas mais c'est
celle là qui compte pour la dernière ok
ok j'ai comme ça la concurrence entre
1,8 et le monde et voilà j'en suis fière
fin de cette vidéo sur super smash speed
speed run heure là si vous a plu si
c'est le cas ne te permet la vidéo comme
d'habitude c'est extrêmement nerveux
comme gameplay et c'est un bordel
monstre à l'écran on s'en doute ravi
dans une nouvelle vidéo merci à vous
regarder tout le monde
b
[Musique]